to illustrate this exchange by some
examples we may find perhaps that
something which perception takes to be
an animal with strong muscles is defined
as an animal organism of high
irritability or what perception takes to
be a condition of great weakness is
defined as a condition of high
sensibility or if we prefer it as an
abnormal affection and moreover a
raising of the to a higher potency
expressions which translate sensuous
facts into Latin and AB and Latin at
that instead of into the notion that an
animal has strong muscles may also be
expressed by the understanding by saying
that the animal possesses a great
muscular force great weakness meeting
similarly a slight force determination
in terms of irritability has this
advantage over determination in terms of
force that the latter expresses
indeterminate but the former determinate
reflection into self for the force
peculiar to muscle is precisely
irritability and irritability is a
preferable determination of strong
muscle sense as in force reflection into
self is already directly employed in it
similarly weakness or slight force
organic passivity has given determinate
expression in terms of sensibility but
when the sensibility is so taken by
itself and fixed and in addition is
bound up with quantitative
determinations and quad rater or less
sensibility as opposed to a greater or
less irritability each is wholly in the
element of sense it is reduced to the
ordinary form of a property what
connects them is not the notion but on
the contrary a quantitative antithesis
which becomes a difference lacking any
thought content though the
indefiniteness of the expressions force
strength and weakness was thereby
eliminated there now arises the equally
futile vague floundering about between
the antithesis of higher and lower
sensibility and irritability
a as they increase and decrease
relatively to one another the
determinations of greater lesser
sensibility or irritability are no less
the unthinking apprehension and
expression of a sensuous phenomenon then
are the holy sensuous determinations of
strength and weakness which are devoid
of any thought content those flawless
expressions have not been replaced by
the notion instead strength and weakness
have been given a determination which
taken solely by itself is based on the
notion which it has for its content but
it loses completely this origin and
character on account of the form of
simplicity and immediacy in which this
content is made into the aspect of the
law and because quantity constitutes the
element of difference in such
determinate determinations the essence
of the content which originally is the
notion and is posited as such retains
the mode of sense perception and remains
as far removed from being cognizant
determined in terms of strength and
weakness or by immediate sense
properties
here in this long paragraph number 282
hingle is not telling us anything
radically new that he hasn't already
been explaining at great length in the
passages preceding this he says that
he's going to provide us with some
examples to try to make this a bit more
concrete for us to allow us to wrap our
heads around as we say in our parlance
and so he's taking in a way he's started
taking a pause before the final push
through the rest of this section of
observing reason where he's going to
turn explicitly in the next paragraph to
say okay now now we really need to
consider the outer not just the inner
and the examples that he provides here
along with a few of science to look at
in a moment the examples that provides
you are not particularly concrete but
they work for what it is that he's
trying to get across I got this or
schema up here to help you visualize
what's what's going on so he says we
might find that something which
perception takes to be an animal with
strong muscles right so we're starting
out at a survey slevin of perception
which is something that we're doing all
the time and observing reason observes
the world through sense perception not
just sense perception because the
understanding is also involved but
senses is very important so the sensuous
aspect of the thing we look at an animal
when we say that animals got strong
muscles you know for and we might think
of all sorts of interesting examples
based on scale you don't think of
animals that we use as as pack animals
or for carrying out specific purposes
like you know the bulldozer of so many
places the elephants you know we might
think of predatory animals that are able
to bring down their prey like the tie
or the lion but we might also think
about other animals who are incredibly
strong in comparison to their size like
for example ants right hands can do and
really animals that have exoskeletons
and that sort of arrangement which
include you know the you know not just
insects but also arthropods we can they
can be incredibly strong of course they
have different kinds of muscle then
don't then these these sorts of muscle
but that's a starting point and we can
talk about any animal having strong
muscles on we might contrast that to a
condition of great weakness as he talks
about and he says we might define that
as an animal organism of high
irritability and that's what we've been
doing you know in contrasting the
external the outer what it is that we're
able to observe through our senses and
then the the inner the inner not being
something that's inside it physically
but rather in ur as in its dynamism what
what is what is going out of it and as
we saw before you know you can have a
cadaver that has strong muscles they're
no longer actually strong so because
there's no you know ability to use them
but you don't have a dead thing that has
a condition of high irritability it has
to be a living organism so he says what
perception cages to be a condition of
great weakness is defined as a condition
of high sensitivity bility or I've got
your sensitivity I will just leave it
there either one is a decent translation
or if we prefer it as an abnormal
affection moreover a raising of it to a
higher potency right so sensibility or
sensitivity is being raised to a higher
level and he go makes a little aside
here at this point which is rather is
Helen yeah I think it's
thing that applies well to his own time
but we might also consider how people
use this sort of terminology not that
Latin terminology but but other
terminology in our own time so he says
these are expressions which translates
sensuous facts into that now that's an
interesting thing say they're not
translating sensuous fats into the
notion or heave it into the objects of
the understanding per se he says they
translate sensuous facts what we might
call the language of perception into a
language that we use to articulate right
so if we think of languages in this
respect as it's not living languages at
the ant I'm lap was used as a scientific
language right and is it still waters
for quite a while after angle if we
think of language is kind of an
artificial system for classifying for
operating on things something that is of
the understanding it's almost like a
code right but it's not a code used by
living beings to you know communicate
with everything it's only used for this
this specific sort of issue or matter
yeah so when we translate it as we do in
that way we're translating it into
something that makes us feel as if
somehow we're getting at the the reality
of it but it's it's really just
providing us with another something
external really something that doesn't
get in the heart of what it is that
we're talking about this is a problem
that has been going on for a long time
people use jargon and substitutes jargon
for actual thinking about things and
they think through jargon in business
language you see a lot of that we're
going to drill
you know that's a very popular phrase at
this time five years from now that's
going to be very outmoded you know
there's all sorts of training things
that people say and you're kind of you
know can get a sense of what they're
supposed to mean but they can mean all
sorts of different things because it
really is no no genuine meaning backing
it that you know that you could you can
point to noting that the understanding
can really latch onto it soothes the
understanding it's very much like what
Hagel was calling description much
earlier on okay so the other side he
says translating sensuous facts into
Latin and a bad Latin at that because
it's not a Latin city whose for anything
other than is communicating between
salons rather than the notion he says
that an animal has strong muscles may be
expressed by the understanding the say
that the animal possesses great muscular
force so we're starting to get a bit
more abstract in moving up that chain
right it's not quite so far as saying
irritability he had Hagel says great
weakness would then similarly me a
slight force right possesses very little
force or his passivity he says now force
he says expresses indeterminate but but
talking in terms of sensitivity to
expresses something more determinate he
says determination in terms of
irritability has an advantage so up at
this level we have a kind of advantage
what is the advantage the lantern force
expresses something indeterminate the
former determinate reflection into self
so we've seen Hagel talk about this over
and over again there is this reflection
into self that is taking place on these
these concepts if we like or these ways
of understanding things the more that
they approximate to the notion the more
living they are the more dynamic they
are so simply
having a condition of great weakness is
not strictly speaking the same thing as
possessing very little force let alone a
condition and high sensibility or high
sensitivity likewise we can say the same
thing as we move up the scale on this
set as we're doing that we're moving
from sense to the understanding right it
doesn't mean that we're leaving sense
sensibility behind or perception behind
but it's being integrated into the
understanding which remember is
ultimately still trying to produce laws
for the things that it's observing so he
goes on any sets when this this you know
when this is taken so by itself in fixed
and in addition is bound up with
quantitative determinations and quad
rater or less sensibility as opposed to
a greater or less irritability each is
wholly in the element of sense it is
reduced to the ordinary form of a
property what connects them is not the
notion these are living the lock right
but on the contrary a quantitative
antithesis which becomes a difference
lagging any thought content this is the
Omega love saying what he's already said
many times before if we're going to try
to make sense of these things solely in
terms of quantitative determinations and
we might say the you know ratios or
determinations or you know observable
connections between these well we're
going to lose sight of what it is that
we're attempting to study and it's much
easier to do this down this level it
becomes you know a bit more difficult
here as we get further up we start to
see that you know these connections that
we're making our pretty ad hoc there's
nothing necessary about them and so
that's what Hagel means about these
quantitative determinations the
differences that are not real
differences you know there's sort of
different difference as he's called it
so many times before now it's
interesting that he says that when we're
doing that we're essentially dealing
with these things in terms of sets
because you might say well wait a second
aren't numbers a matter for the
understanding yes they are why they're
not a matter for the whole understanding
there you might say a matter for the
understanding insofar as the
understanding is operating like
something that's just involved with
perception right you could have you
could quibble of course when we get to
the very interesting branches of
mathematics but Hagel is not really
attuned to that you know some of the
developments that are going to take
place in mathematics later on he's
thinking in terms of what it is that
scientists actually purport not always
do but purport to do which is to measure
things and to try to come up with you
know reasoned connections between these
things based on the quantifiable data as
we know in our own time there's all
sorts of problems that come up with it
particularly when we're not just dealing
with organisms which are tough enough
but systems of human beings the social
sciences but that's a whole different
thing that we're going to talk about a
little bit later on so it was Emily says
through the indefiniteness of the
expressions force or strength or
weakness the Millea was eliminated their
nama arises the equally fuel with a
flowering about between the antithesis
of higher and lower sensibility or
irritability as they increase or
decrease relatively to each other we saw
him trying this out for size and saying
no that's not going to work in an
earlier paragraph where he talked about
these these you know attempts to
introduce ratios and you can certainly
do that there is like a cheese meant
that's possible you could you know right
about you measure things
put it in a journal but unfortunately
you lost sight of what it is that you
were actually supposed to be measuring
which is the thing the organic being and
it says the determinations of greater or
lesser sensibility of your ability then
are no less the unthinking apprehension
and expression of a sensuous phenomenon
right then then are the holy sensuous
determinations of strength and weakness
which would avoided any flat habit so
the trouble is if we're going to read
this sort of thing in to here or in to
here we're going to end up lowering
these to the level of of just sense and
sense perception now why would we do
that well you know it's jumping ahead a
little bit what is the what is reason
aiming at this entire time laws and
thinks that law does have to be framed
in that sort of manner and if it can't
do that then one has to bring the
materials down to the level of the
sensuous so that it can do it in the
process it's going to lose grasp on the
notion Hagel says that the notion is
still grounding everything but it's
being misunderstood in the process so he
says those thoughtless expressions have
not been replaced by the notion that's
the goal right to replace them by the
notion instead strength and weakness
have been given a determination which
taken solely by itself is based on the
notion which it has for its content
right but it's lost the form of the
notion that's a problem right what does
it mean to lose the form of the notion
in part because this is a sort of thing
that we have to unpack and at length I
would say in part it means losing sight
of what it was that you were actually
engaged in and your own role as
consciousness in participating it
that's implicit in the Galleon you know
no [ __ ] the beaker if the concept so he
goes on he says on account of the form
of simplicity and immediacy in which
this content is made into the aspect of
a law and because quantity constitutes
the element of difference the existence
of the content which originally is the
notion and is posited as such as we
started with trying to make sense of a
notion retains the motive sense
perception and it remains as far or make
Marines as far removed from being
colonized as when determined in terms of
strength and weakness by immediate sense
properties so so more as we are
attempting to deal with the organic
being and its properties or its
functions like irritability sense of
sensibility reproduction in terms of you
know what's going on down here which is
more manageable we're losing sight of it
and we're really engaging and what hegel
would be willing to call unscientific
science things can postulate themselves
as being scientific because they use the
apparatus of science or because they
make some vague appeal to scientific
method right but it really be scientific
to be you know vision chef lika means to
grasp how things connect with each other
and to grasp the adequacy of what it is
that one is up to in this case we're
talking about observation of nature and
specifically observation of that part of
nature that turned out to be quite
intractable mainly organic nature
now there still remains to be considered
solely on its own account what the outer
aspect of organic being is and how in it
the antithesis of its inner and outer is
determined just as at first the inner of
the whole in relation to its own outer
was considered
on the heels of a very long paragraph we
now have this very short paragraph
number 283 in which Hagel is pivoting us
so to speak so we just had a paragraph
where he was reminding us of all sorts
of interesting things but not really
contributing anything new and now in
this very short condensed paragraph he's
going to open up a new door and this may
be something that you've been wondering
about as we've gone through the previous
paragraphs he starts off by saying that
there's still something that needs to be
considered on its own and I don't want
to get the impression that there's only
one thing that still needs to be
considered at its own because there are
many many many many things coming up
we're only about a third of the way into
the work so there's a lot of other stuff
head to go but at least with respect to
the organic substance the organic being
the the organism there he says there's
still something that needs to be
considered on its own account through
busy align you know for itself apart
from from other things we've we've dealt
with it we've touched upon it but we
haven't quite gotten into that yet so
he's promising us what we're going to be
engaging within the paragraphs yet to
come now do you remember we talked about
in the past the inner having both an
inner of the inner and an hour of the
inner that was discussed quite a while
ago we also have this notion of the
inner expressing itself in the outer and
this law that the outer is the
expression of the inner here Hagel is
going to say what we need to attend to
at this point now that this stuff is
unimportant but what we really need to
pay attention to now is how something
similar to what goes on with the inner
occurs with the other so that the outer
itself has an inner and an outer you
might call it the outermost outer right
and what we're translating here at
in Miller as antithesis could be
translated as opposition the Gaians
autumn how are these distinguished from
each other how do these relate to each
other how are these connected with each
other and also you know how do they
connect fact to this stuff that as well
so he says just as first the inner of
the whole in relation to its own outer
was was considered we're now going to
consider the outer in terms of these two
sides of it or you might say it's inside
and it's outside
the outer considered by itself is the
structured shape in general the system
of life articulating itself in the
element of being and at the same time
essentially the being for an other of
the organism objective being in its
being for self this other appears in the
first instance as its outer inorganic
nature if these two are considered in
relation to a law the inorganic nature
cannot as we saw above constitute the
aspect of a law over against the
organism because the latter is at the
same time absolutely for itself and has
a universal and free relation to
inorganic nature
following up immediately on the previous
paragraph paragraph 284 is going to turn
to considering the outer of organic
beings the organism considered by itself
for Izzy the track that in the German
and what hindle is going to sing here
should remind us of some of the earlier
movements that were occurring that he's
referring back to in the 250
specifically in paragraph 255 much
earlier in this section right so he's
going to tell us several things about
what we find out when we consider the
outer of the organic nature on its own
account one is that we're talking about
structured shape in general so consider
the human body you know there's there's
a paper positive east alton whoever halt
you know you can identify me as having
this particular you're sheltering that
hopefully is the same as what if you
have to work with it unless these
signals from youtube somehow end up you
know being understood by some other kind
of animal other than human beings in
which case i suppose things get much
more interesting speculations like that
aside what we have as a structured shape
it in general the outer of the beating
we also have as Hagel says and here what
we see is the the inner sort of
expressing itself through the outer you
don't have the outer totally without
theater this he calls it a system of
life articulating itself in the element
of being what is the element of being
mean well it's articulating itself in
this in in reality it has to take on
determinacy in fact much determinacy but
life as we've seen is not itself
indeterminate but rather a flux
something that has a freedom and
Harrington not a freedom of choice but a
deeper kind of freedom which allows if
they have a dynamism
that allows it to in certain respects
transcend any one particular
configuration so when we talk about a
system of life what we're talking about
here is a system whose parts and whose
orientations and organizations are
changing over time it still remains an
organic system then the third thing that
he tells us this is where we get to the
very interesting part is that the outer
the external as the being for another of
the organism that is the organism you
know we can talk about its dynamism its
inner and all these three interesting
functions all the haters we can make
more reproduction irritability
Sensibility you know all that great
stuff right it has to have a locus in
the world and the outer is where we
connect up with the world this is you
know similar to the you know the
mind-body problem that bedeviled people
so much in early modern philosophy but
we're really interesting about the
mind-body problem was not just splitting
things into dualities and all that or
you know can we reduce it all the one
thing and thinking about it how does
something that clearly is different than
its external environment something that
appears to be you know perhaps even a
different kind of substance how does
that intersect with not reduced to but
intersect with and interact with this
whole world out here and only two
different options you can fold it all
into the minds everything's mind if the
hill is path the materialist path is to
rather implausibly suggest well we can
just reduce everything to matter we
don't know how to do that all that's
very very interesting but we want to put
that site but we're concentrating out
here he has to do with the fact that
every single organism insofar as it's an
organism not even necessarily conscious
this is not just about
sciousness but about life in so far as
it is living it becomes something that
has an interior already that is
different from the rest of world except
insofar as there are other interior or
ities out there right Hagel's not going
to go there quite yet in this para so
the outer is the being for another being
for something else of an organism which
itself is as he says something that is
for us if he calls it here we go
objective being and it's being for self
right so what is that other well there's
lots of possibilities for that but here
Hagel perverts to talking about
inorganic nature he says the other at
first which would be plenty of others
coming along right is outer inorganic
nature this is what we encountered
earlier on like I said in the 250s he
says this other is the two are
considered in relation to a law right if
we're trying to provide laws what's the
tendency he says the inorganic nature
can not as we saw above constitute the
aspect of the law over against the
organs so what what is he talking about
their well you try to take the this
which is more observable the outer
organic nature and say well you know
cold climates produce fur right we saw
this as an example or you know other
people did things produce other things
environment produces the externality the
outer of the organism and thereby
produces the the organism has what it is
Hagel says no no no it doesn't really
work like that we've already seen some
of the problems with that and Hagel
brings up this issue of freedom again
we're not talking anything like
political freedom or even that you know
the freedom that people like to talk
about being able to like see two
different options and choose them we're
talking about something in a more basic
here the fact that life will find some
sort of you know slippery dodge to move
out from the determinism that our
organic nature which does operate
according to some sort of determinism
wants to apply to it that is part of
what it means to be life sometimes light
will be determined by its environment
but that's not because the the
environment itself has absolute
determinative capacity that just crushes
you know the organism under it and makes
it part of that system though rather it
has to do with the organism being
receptive to that sort of thing so he
goes on he says the the ladder the the
organism is at the same time absolutely
for itself right the before itself means
to have some degree of freedom he says
it has a universal and free relation to
inorganic nature which means that really
we have to look at things this way
rather than attempting to simply derive
laws this way that's going to be a bit
more difficult but it requires us now to
turn our attention to this side